[Music]
super villains
[Music]
sad cells in costumes wanting you to
think they're all
dark and deep what's the like
living life as a punchline
but all i would take would be one
blessed act of rebellion
for you to restore your dignity in its
entirety
[Music]
you know the deal complete the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
love him or hate him these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few
days
any questions and yes
that is your hand very good we're all
gonna die
i hope so oh for god's sake
this is suicide oh that's kind of our
thing
like a bloodbath to start the day
they call you peacemaker
i cherish peace with all my heart i
don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it
i thought you were the crazy one oh yeah
here's the deal we failed a mission you
died we find out any information you
give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no
[Music]
you